una nueva medida en contra de moscú los
ministros de finanzas del g7 llegaron a
un acuerdo para imponer un tope a los
precios del petróleo ruso y sus
derivados la medida solamente permitirá
el traslado del petróleo si es vendida a
un precio igual o menor al fijado por la
coalición los ministros del bloque
conformado por eeuu francia alemania
canadá reino unido italia y japón-
confirmaron el objetivo de la decisión
queremos limitar los ingresos de rusia
al mismo tiempo reducir el daño
económico a nuestras sociedades este
tope de precio en las exportaciones de
petróleo ruso están diseñados para
reducir los ingresos de putin para
cerrar una importante fuente de
financiación para esta guerra de
agresión al mismo tiempo queremos
contener los aumentos de los precios
mundiales de energía para minimizar la
inflación a nivel mundial es vender más
mínimo inflación global el g7 asegura
que buscará a formar una coalición más
amplia con otros países que se sumen a
la iniciativa el kremlin por su parte
advirtió que suspendería los envíos de
crudo a los países que se adhieran este
tope lo que según ellos conduciría a una
desestabilización del mercado mundial
el viceprimer ministro alexander novak
declaró de manera inequívoca y clara que
aquellos países que se unan al techo de
precios no estarían entre los que
recibirán petróleo ruso
simplemente no cooperaremos con ellos
sobre petróleo en tales principios no
comerciales
el precio que se establecerá como tope
dependerá de aspectos técnicos y aún
está por definirse sin embargo algunos
responsables del g7 han expresado su
escepticismo ante la medida si no se
implican otros grandes compradores de
petróleo ruso como lo son china e india
países que han aumentado su consumo
desde el inicio de la invasión de
ucrania